you're in a class it's near the
beginning of the semester you write an
exam or you hand in an essay and you
don't get the mark that you desired okay
so what are your options well one option
would be so you've hit an anomaly things
didn't happen the way you wanted them to
happen and so maybe you say jeez that
was a boring and stupid class anyways
this gives me an excuse to get out and
so that's not such a negative thing or
you think oh well I really better buckle
down and study and you decide to stay in
the class so basically what you've done
is maintained your framework I'm going
to work through this class but you're
you've decided to modify some of the
subroutines that make up that frame you
say well I should study more next time
or I have to prioritize this class
compared to other classes so it's a
micro alteration within the overarching
framework but another thing you can do
is say to hell with the class I just
I'll just drop it and so the advantage
to that is problem gone the
disadvantages well now you have a
different problem which is okay fine you
drop the class do you have another class
that you can replace it with is that a
good way of dealing with a micro failure
you know to move up a level of analysis
and throughout the whole frame because
you could also say well maybe I should
just drop out of university and maybe I
should go hang myself you know that's
well it's the same line of logic it's
just taken up to a higher degree of
abstraction and so generally speaking
you don't want to solve a problem by
moving up a level and wiping out the
frame within which the problem was
experienced you you want to do that
carefully because in principle the frame
that you were working within had already
you'd already assigned value to it and
worked out it you've already invested in
it too big sacrifice to blow out the
whole frame now sometimes you can do it
so anyways what happens is well it gets
a bad grade and you're upset about it
and so you've been plunged from your
happy satiated state let's say into a
state of relative chaos and the chaos is
oh I hit an obstacle I didn't expect it
and now I don't know what to do and so
what does it mean to not know what to do
well
it can mean I need to study harder it
can mean I should drop this course it to
mean I should major in a different
subject it mean maybe I shouldn't be in
university it could mean maybe my future
plans have been formulated badly it can
mean my future plans have been
formulated badly because I don't
understand myself very well and I've
been telling lies about my past right
the thing can really expand on you and
that's what the chaotic domain is that's
the reman efest a ssin of those things
that you had considered irrelevant right
because when you go to pick up the exam
you've got your identity as a competent
student intact you're not questioning
whether you should be in the course or
whether you should be in that major or
whether you should be in university none
of that that's all in the implicitly
accepted category and as soon as the
anomalous event emerges all of those
things that you had rendered axiomatic
start to become questionable and that's
like the shark coming up out coming up
from the depths to pull you down and
that's the classic way of representing
that and of symbolizing it that's Jonah
and the Whale for example so if
something is manifest itself from the
deep unknown and pulls you under like an
alligator at a waterhole which is I'm
sure one of the sources from which we
derived that particular kind of
mythological representation because you
could imagine that when we were on the
veldt after living on trees we had to go
down to the damn water holes and you've
you've watched enough nature programs to
know what a Nile crocodile can do to a
water buffalo it's not pretty and so to
go down to the water the chaotic water
and the source of all life as well right
is to risk an encounter with the
terrible thing that lurks in the depths
and so we use that as a central metaphor
for for for mapping the sorts of things
that haven't happened to us in a much
more abstract space and you know that
because one of the things you're going
to do let's say that the the professor
there's a professor obviously who gave
you the bad grade okay so one logical
presupposition is that you're in some
sense insufficient in relationship to
the course but another logical
and instantaneous categorization is to
throw that person into the category of
malevolent predator and you'll do that
by becoming upset and cursing the person
in your imagination